[Musique]
c'était heure de pause
bonjour madame richier elle te prends
pour une conne tout le monde fait ce
qu'il veut de toi est trop gentil comme
ton mari trop bon trop con
nous avons le regret de vous informer
que votre frère est décédé la semaine
dernière vous héritez donc de la maison
de famille ainsi que 100% des parts de
la société kinta dounam ou exploitants
de vin de porto en la justice mais
qu'est ce qu'ils vont penser ils vont
penser que maria josé ça fait 30 ans
qu'ils bossent comme des acharnés qui
méritent ce qui leur arrive tu avoir ma
maison pour tekken pas soyez ma propre
soeur qui me dit rien à moi à moi mais
rien va partir au poteau je sais que je
portais première savoir alors je me
disais mon ami josé
il doit avoir envie d'autre chose oui on
peut accrocher une remorque derrière moi
je donne morte
nous sommes tous bien d'accord il faut
absolument le garder dans l'immeuble
papa maman alors voilà je suis amoureux
et s'appelle pas la peau larribe héros
c'est une excellente nouvelle pole à
elle veut pas d'importance si charles
cailleux va faire à dîner dans la merde
tous ensemble autour d'un gaspacho ccg
en train de me demander si les portugais
scène gaspachos est ce qu'on va faire
tous les tous seuls dans cette grande
maison chez renault bono et évolué
depuis la dictature du général alcazar
ça devient terrible salazar alcazar
c'est certain je les confonds toujours
les deux toujours pensé que ce soir on
mangerait de l'amour
[Musique]